[Musique]
de sa famille qui s'est occupé de toi ta
mère ton père les deux un oncle une
tante un grand parent ou autre alors il
faut savoir que ces grands mots dont
clochard de vaud canal qui m'a récupéré
quand j'étais petit puisque
effectivement on va déposer mes parents
mes géniteurs m'ont déposé dans le canal
évasion et je dois tout à mon goût mais
aussi de là où il est il me regarde mais
aussi à thouars ont beau diable et ciu
en france on est encore loin de
l'égalité hommes femmes
bien sûr puisque si moi j'arrivais que
je donne deux zips et au cul tu as match
où je serai l'ennemi public numéro 1
tandis que mme achour à me tabasser avec
un fer à repasser et un bal et un bateau
de balai elle aura quand même raison en
période de fort chômage les emplois
devaient être réservés en priorité aux
hommes d'accord pas d'accord pas
d'accord mais alors on a déjà fait trop
de fois les femmes doivent aller
travailler
nous les gardons nos sponsors hockey
bière maggio football ligue des
champions
machin tranquille as tu déjà fumé un
joint avec tes parents
alors comme je le disais un petit peu
plus haut je dois tout à vent debout qui
m'a recueillie look effectivement on
avait tout loisir le dimanche de faire
de longues sessions au 2ème shit et
souvent quand j'étais sage à noël on
avait droit à quelques boulettes de cac
mais bon ça reste entre nous c'est assez
privé s'est passé à cesson
[Musique]